المترجم: Khaled Ali
المدقّق: Mohamed Hussein
مرحباً
بدايةً أعرّفكم بنفسي
إسمي "يمان أبو جيب"
خرّيج كلّية الهندسة الكهربائية
باختصاص الطاقات المتجددة من جامعة دمشق
أغلب الناس تعرف "يمان" كفائز
في الموسم السّابع من مسابقة (نجوم العلوم)
واليوم سأكشف السّر
الذي جعلني أشعر بفرحة الفوز
والذي جعلني أحد المتحدّثين اليوم
في محادثة TEDx
منذ صغري وأنا معجب بالهندسة
وكنت متأكداً أنني خُلِقتُ لكي أكون مهندساً
لكني لا أذكر أنني فكّرت في يوم من الأيام
أن أكون مخترعاً
أو أن يقال عنّي مخترع
لماذا ؟
ربّما لأني لم أجد أحداً
يوقظ المخترع في داخلي
أذكر تماماً, في يومِ خميس
من عام 2011
كنتُ في السّنة الأولى في الجامعة
كنا نشاهد التلفاز أنا و أبي
كعادتنا في يوم الخميس
فصادفنا برنامجاً
يناقش واقع المخترعين العرب
بصراحة لم أصدّق عينيّ
أصبحت أتابع حلقات البرنامج بشغف
لكي أكتشف إنجازات المخترعين و خلفياتهم
لفت نظري مخترع مصريّ
قام بصنع لصاقة
توضع تحت الأسطح العازلة للكهرباء
لتجعلها ناقلة
كمهندس, أرى أنّ ذلك إنجاز عظيم
أصبحتُ أتابع هذا المخترع بشغف خلال الحلقات
و أرى كيف أنّه ينتقل من مرحلة إلى أخرى
محافظاً على الصّدارة
و وصل إلى النهائيات وتمكّن من تحقيق اللقب
بعد ذلك أغلقت التلفاز وقلت لأبي بعفويّة
هذا المخترع خارقٌ للعادة
في تلك اللحظة
شعرتُ بالفارق الكبير بيني وبينه
يسكت أبي للحظات ثم يقول
صدّقني ستكون مكانه في يوم من الأيام
لا أخفيكم أنني
لم آخذ كلامه على محمل الجد في البداية
ظننته كأيّ أب, يحب أن يرى ابنه ناجحاً
سواءٌ كان إبنه يستحقّ ذلك أو لا
بعد ذلك فكّرت
أنا أدرس الهندسة
في السّنة الأولى في جامعة دمشق
وذلك المخترع خريّج من جامعة مصريّة
وبلدينا متكافئين من الناحية العلميّة
فأنا لا أقارن نفسي مع شخص
يدرس في معهد ماساتشوستس
بظروف مختلفة عنّي
ولو كانت تلك المقارنة ممكنة أحياناً
لذلك في اليوم التالي
كانت بداية جديدة بالنسبة لي
بداية شخص يريد ترك بصمة في الحياة
يكون وجوده في الدنيا مختلف عن بقية الناس
الذين لا يقدمون للبشرية أي شيء
اشتركت في دورات لتعلّم اللغة
وبحثت في الإنترنت
عن مواضيع الطاقة المتجددة
و خاصّةً الطاقة الشمسية
و قرأت أحدث الأبحاث عنها
في السنة الثانية و الثالثة
أصبحت أبني مشاريعاً
و كنت في الفريق
الذي ركّب أحد أكبر المشاريع في وقته
و هو مشروع 15 كيلو واط في مدينة درعا
في السنة الرابعة
وبسبب الانقطاع المستمرللتيار الكهربائي
وحرارة الجو المرتفعة في الصيف
خطرت لي فكرة اختراع مكيف
يعمل على الطاقة الشمسية
يكون سعره زهيد و بمنتاول الجميع
الفقراء و الاغنياء
توجّهت إلى السوق, قمت بتركيب القطع
و صوّرت فيديو على موقع يوتيوب
شرحت فيه عن هذا الإختراع خطوة بخطوة
تفاجئت بالكم الهائل
من التعليقات والاعجابات التي تلقّيتها
والرسائل الخاصة التي يشكرني فيها الناس
لأنني خففت عنهم حرارة الصيف
شعرت بسعادة لا توصف
يمكنني إخباركم عنها لكنني
أتمنى أن يجربها كل واحد منكم
أن تساعد شخصاً لا تعرفه, دون مقابل
في ذلك الوقت عرفت معنى الإختراع
الإختراع هو أن تحل مشاكلك أو مشاكل محيطك
سواء بطريقة صعبة ومعقدة
أو سهلة و بسيطة
طالما أنك توجد حلّاً لمشكلة, فهو اختراع
لكن ما هي تلك المشاكل التي تتطلب الحل
منزلي يعمل بأكمله على الطاقة الشمسية
منذ عام 2008
باستثناء بعض الأجهزة و أهمها الغسالة
كلّما انقطع التيار الكهربائي, تقول لي أمي
نريد حلّاً لمشكلة الغسيل
أنا الآن طالب هندسة
يجب أن أحلّ مشاكلي بنفسي
لذلك درست آليّة عمل الغسالة
ومكوناتها وكيفية استهلاكها للطاقة
و بعد دراسة هندسية
تمكنت من تخفيض استطاعة الغسالة بنسبة 88%
واستطعت إيجاد طريقة
لتوفير استهلاك الماء فيها
خطر في بالي برنامج المسابقات (نجوم العلوم)
تأكّدت من الانترنت
أنه لم يسبقني أحد لفكرة الغسالة
قمت بتعبئة استمارة الاشتراك بالبرنامج
و فعلاً, تجاوزت المرحلة الأولى
و وصلت إلى النهائي
و كنت بذلك أول سوري يصل الى النهائي
ويحقق اللقب منذ سبع سنوات
لم يتمكن خلالها أي سوري
من الوصول للنهائيات
بعد الفوز, كنت في الدوحة
وأبي موجود في دمشق
اتصلت به و قبل أن أقول مرحباً
أو يقول هو مبروك
قلت له: أتذكر يوم الخميس
ما قلته لي آنذاك هو ما أوصلني إلى هنا
ما أحاول أن أقوله من خلال هذه القصة
أن كل شخص منا, فيه بذرة مبتكر
وفنان ومبدع أو خلّاق
لكنه يحتاج إلى شرارة تشعل هذه المواهب
سواء أنت أشعلتها, أو أشعلها شخص آخر
القرار لك, أن تكون متميز و مبدع
أو أن تكون عاديّاً كبقية الناس
لن يذكرك أحد بعد وفاتك
كشباب سوريين كان لدينا ذلك الخيار
أن نكون عاديين أو مبتكرين
أما الآن و بعد الحرب في عام 2011
أصبحنا ملزمين أن نكون مبدعين
أصبحنا أمام مسؤولية أخلاقية وتاريخية
لأننا مسؤولون عن إعادة إعمار بلدنا
لن يعمرها أحد غيرنا
(تصفيق)
تكلمت كثيراً عن الاختراع
و سيسألني الناس الأن
كيف نصبح مخترعين ونحن أشخاص عاديون؟
من تجربتي الشخصية المتواضعة
و من خلال ملاحظتي لأشخاص مبدعين
اكتشفت أن الاختراع ببساطة
هو تحقيق التوازن بين العلوم النظرية
التي نتعلمها في الجامعة و المدرسة
وبين الحياة العملية
التي نواجه فيها مشكلاتنا
عندما نطبق ما نتعلمه في الجامعة من أساسيات
حتى لو كانت أساسيات قديمة
إلا أنها موجودة في أنحاء العالم
عندما نطبق هذه العلوم النظرية
و ننقلها إلى الواقع
هذا هو الاختراع و الابداع
و نكون حللنا مشاكلنا
تكلمت عن مسابقة نجوم العلوم وما قبلها
برأيي المرحلة الأهم هي
مرحلة ما بعد المسابقة
سأتكلم في جانبين أساسيين
الجانب الأول, سأتكلم عن يمان رائد الأعمال
وصاحب الاختراع
يتمنى ويعمل على إيصال اختراعه إلى الاسواق
وعلى منافسة المنتجات الأخرى
ستقولون لي, و إذا لم تساعدك الظروف
ماذا ستفعل؟
الحل بسيط, و هو أن يكون لديك خطة
"أ" و "ب" و "ج"
وفي الوضع الراهن نحن بحاجة الى
عشرات الخطط البديلة
كل شاب و فتاة بحاجة إلى خطط كثيرة
لأنك قد لا تجد الأبواب مفتوحة
في أول 14 خطة
فتصل إلى هدفك في الخطة رقم 15
لذلك لا تسمح لباب واحد مغلق أن يوقفك
دائماً إجعل لديك خططاً بديلة
و بناءً على هذا الكلام
أنا أعمل الآن على اختراعين جديدين
أنجزت ما يقارب 70% منهما
بالإضافة إلى عملي في مشروع آخر
كي لا أقول في يوم من الأيام
أنني فعلت ما بوسعي و لم أجد من يدعمني
هل أتوقف؟
بالطبع لا
لأن يمان هو من اخترع
و ليس الاختراع هو الذي أوجد يمان
الجانب الثاني, هو التأثير على المجتمع
نحن دائماً بحاجة لأشخاص مؤهلين
ليكونوا قدوة لنا لنتعلم منهم ونقلد تجاربهم
كما قلّدتُ تجربة غيري
فأنا أطمح أن أنقل تجربتي إلى الشباب
وقطعت عهداً
بعد أن فزت في مسابقة نجوم العلوم
أن أنقل تجربة الابتكار والابداع
للشباب السوري
الذين عايشوا الحرب
ولم تساعدهم الظروف لكي يبدعوا
برأيي أن الابداع هو سباق تتابع
كلّ شخص سيمشي مسافة معينة
و يسلّم الرسالة الى الشخص التالي
ليكمل عنه أو يعمل معه
ولذلك قمتُ بالمشاركة في فعالية تدعى
Startup Weekend Youth Of Damascus
و هي فعالية يشارك فيها شبان
بأعمار من 14 الى 18 سنة
لديهم أفكار أو ابتكارات أو مشاريع
يحاولون إنشاء نموذج أولي لفكرتهم
لكي يعيشوا هذه التجربة
عندما اتصل بي المنظمون
قالوا لي نريدك أن تكون أحد الموجّهين
فوراً وافقت
لكن بصراحة قلت في نفسي
"لن يعرفك أحد هناك فتلك الفئة العمرية
تهتم بالرياضة والمغنيين والرقص"
كما في جميع دول العالم
بصراحة تلك الفكرة تلاشت كُلياً و للأبد
بعد أن التقيت بأول مجموعتين
وجدتُ أنهم شبابٌ واعٍ لديه قدرٌ كبير
من المسؤولية والثقافة والعلم
بشكل جعلني مصدوماً
سأضرب مثالين
من الأشخاص الذين تابعتهم في الفعالية
الأول يدعى "ياسر" وهو من الحاضرين معنا
و أتشرف بأنني دعوته اليوم
لأنني معجب بشخصيّته و بعمله
ياسر تعرّض للحرمان من والده منذ 3 سنوات
المتوقّع من "ياسر" أن ينهار
أمام تلك الفاجعة
خاصّة في تلك المرحلة العمرية الحساسة
عمره 16 عام وفقد والده عندما كان في 13
لن ألومه في حال استسلم و لم يكمل مشاريعه
فتلك المرحلة
هي مرحلة تكوين شخصيّته و تفكيره
لكنه لم يستسلم وثابر وابتكر وأبدع
ونال المركز الثاني مع فريقه
في تلك الفعالية
و أقول بصراحة أن مشروعه جيد بما يكفي
ليكون مشروع تخرّج من المعهد الهندسي
و هو ما يزال في 16 من عمره
أؤكد أن مشروعه يصلح ليكون مشروع هندسي
الشخص الآخر يدعى "حمدي"
و كان أصغر المشاركين
عمره 14 عاماً
للأسف لم يكن من الفائزين
شعرت بغصّة داخله
قلت له بعد نهاية الفعالية: كم عمرك؟
قال لي 14 عام
قلت له: تأكد أنني عندما كنت في عمرك
لم أكن مشاركاً في أيّ حدث
و أن أول مسابقة ربحتُ فيها كان عمري 22 سنة
تأكد أنك بعمر 22 عام
ستكون قد فزت في أحد المسابقات العلمية
شعرت بالتغيير الذي طرأ على "حمدي"
بسبب كلامي
شعرت وقتها بسعادة لا توصف
أكثر من سعادة الفوز في "نجوم العلوم"
و شعرت أنني نقلت له تجربة و أنني أعمل على
تطوير مجتمعي وليس نفسي فقط
ونحن موجودون لكي ننشر
العلم والثقافة وتجاربنا الناجحة
دون أن نتفاخر بها
فأنا لا أفكر في استعراض عملي
أنا لا أريد أن يعاني اي شخص
مما عانيته أنا سابقاً
عندما كان الناس يقولون لي:
هناك ألف شخص غيرك, لن تفلح في شيء
فهذا الشخص "حمدي", تم غرس بذرة صالحة داخله
من قبل أهله ومحيطه ومدرسته وأصدقائه
لذلك سيكون شخصاً صالحاً في المجتمع
هناك آلاف الأشخاص مثل "ياسر" و "حمدي"
هؤلاء الأشخاص متأكد أنهم سيحملون المسؤولية
و سيكون مستقبلنا و مستقبل سوريا بخير
لأنهم وجدوا الاستثمار الصحيح
أغلب الناس تعتقد أن الاستثمار
هو فقط الاستثمار المالي
الأرباح و رأس المال و هكذا
هذا هو المعنى الضيق للاستثمار
لكن الاستثمار الناجح و المجدي للمجتمع
ماليّاً واجتماعياً واخلاقياً
هو الاستثمار بالانسان نفسه
عزيزتي الأم, ستكونين مبدعة عندما
تستثمرين في أولادك ليكون أشخاصاً صالحين
عزيزي المعلم, ستكون مبدعاً عندما
تستثمر في طلابك ليكونوا في أعلى المراتب
فنجاحهم هو نجاح لك
عزيزي التاجر و الصناعي, إذا وجدت طالباً
ليس لديه الامكانيات المادية ليكمل دراسته
فمسؤوليتك أن تساعده ليكون
طبيباً أو مهندساً أو عاملاً محترفاً
فالاستثمار الناجح
هو الاستثمار بالانسان و ليس بالمادة
في النهاية, شكراً لكم و لحسن استماعكم
السلام عليكم
(تصفيق)